analyst Angier and her family are
heading to an area in northern Kenya
where they've been told there's enough
water and pasture for her livestock it
will take them a day to walk there
there's a drought in parts of Kenya
months of rain have just ended but
weather experts say it wasn't enough and
millions of people are likely to suffer
worsening food and water shortages it
did not rain where we were so we had to
come this way to a settlement area where
my animals can survive hadas from
different parts of this region are
bringing their animals to area such as
maralell wait has rained but frequent
droughts and scarcity of resources often
causes conflict between Harding
communities many of the conflicts begin
from watering points cattle markets and
grazing areas like this one and it takes
so little to start a fight which can
spiral out of control and trigger
revenge by communities these are elders
from neighboring Subaru and Picatta
ethnic groups they started peace
meetings after 10 years of fighting
killed hundreds of people
Dominique Ellis its father was killed
while trying to break up a gunfight
let's eat who was then a teenager was
also shot by a stray bullet
he says fighting in some areas has
worsened because of the easy access to
guns political interference and cattle
rustling dry when poor coat is dry they
come here because it is green when
Sambora was dry we go to Portland when
they come here they steal our cattle
when we go there we steal their cattle
and the cycle keeps repeating itself
it's a job of elders in Maryland to
ensure peace among neighbors every so
often they come together at this highest
point of the Rift Valley a neutral
ground they discussed how to handle the
large number of hardest arriving from
other drought-hit areas we also started
a peace market pockets and samborose who
neighbor each other live in cohesion but
those who live far from here are the
ones causing problems we are also trying
to talk to them those helping to keep
the peace including the Catholic Church
say those such meetings are a good start
ethnic fighting is common in some parts
of northern Kenya people are moving from
community on land to individual
ownership so that's going to pose a
serious threat because there will be no
more land to move with the life stuff
for now hardest coming tomorrow
enjoy relative safety negotiated by
their elders those from distant areas
are warned against starting trouble
one mistake may take the communities
here back to a conflict they've worked
so hard to avoid Catherine saw
al-jazeera Samburu Kenya